um it's nice to meet another american
idol person it's funny
we've never met but i feel like it
doesn't matter what season you're from
or
it's like a camp like it's sometimes
when you run into people
i'm always like oh hey we don't know
each other but we kind of do because
wellness
you you have a like an unspoken bond
with everybody who does idle because
yeah because it's like nobody else
understands what it's like to be on that
show and then you meet people that
you're like you know
exactly what i went through and what you
just get thrown into it's crazy
what season were you one i was on season
nine
i always get confused because it was in
2010 so but i was one of the youngest on
my season i was like 16
so wow i went from singing like at my
high school talent show to then
being thrust into wow i was 19. so i was
at least few years older that's yeah
and i sang the same uh audition song as
you oh it laughed yeah
oh my gosh so here's the reason why i
sang it is i literally didn't know it
was a tv show because it was the first
season i had no idea what i was
auditioning for i just
thought it might pay um and and i was
singing it at a wedding
and so i was like i'll just sing it
because whatever and i love that song i
love that song
and i was like i was the young one with
the old soul
and then uh when we got to the live
shows the judges kept telling me that
they wanted me to be younger
and in my head i was like young who's
young and fun
kelly clarkson oh so what did you say i
sang
breakaway and unfortunately it was my
worst performance yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever
help